we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a caller
complaining about the time that we do
the show each day
hey David I'd like to know why
um you can't do your show same day in
the afternoon
um so that it's more up to date and that
you're not recording yesterday's news
period
yeah listen
um we
no matter what time we do the show
someone has a problem with it we
actually used to do the show later in
the day we used to film more like three
or four o'clock and then it would go out
by like seven or so and what that led to
is that many of our affiliate stations
couldn't air it until the next day and
the first YouTube clips would publish
around seven or eight but then more of
the clips wouldn't publish until the
next day with the podcast people who go
to the gym in the morning or afternoon
in the afternoon more likely they would
write and they'd say you know David I go
to the gym at three four five six the
podcast isn't out till seven or eight so
I'm not hearing it until a full 24 hours
later people didn't like that there's
always some issue but the bottom line is
as follows think of all the platforms
we're producing for
and genuinely to get the show out the
fastest what we found is we record in
the very early afternoon late morning
early afternoon the audio podcast is out
by 2 30 PM Eastern usually that's still
11 30 a.m in the west and that really
feels pretty good without dealing with
this like starting to bleed over into
the next day thing remember also that as
a member you can get the full commercial
free audio or video feeds usually by
like 3 P.M Eastern that's noon on the
west coast so that's the schedule I get
it's not a perfect schedule for
everybody we have some stations that say
we'd like to run it at two but you don't
get it to us till three okay so those
stations have to run the show the next
day we're doing the best we can given
that we have an audience across so many
different time zones usually it's a
combination of stories from the later
half of the previous day and that
morning I mean on today's show there's
stuff that happened this morning that is
on the show so I don't even agree with
the idea that we're like a day behind
but certainly when Trump's Mar-A-Lago
speech is at 8 30 PM that's going to be
on the next day's show it's sort of
inevitable when when Trump doesn't get
out of his arraignment until almost 4
P.M it's very tough to have that on that
day's show we review it the next day and
one other thing I'll say it's not the
end of the world to give a little bit of
space particularly with stories where
you want to get as many of the details
included and correct in the show so I
feel pretty okay with the schedule right
now always open to hearing thoughts from
others we've got a great bonus show for
you today we'll talk about the Bud Light
boycott from the right wing it's a wild
wild one we will talk about a new North
Carolina North Carolina lawmaker
switching parties and we will talk about
a judge ordering Stormy Daniels to pay
Trump another 120 Grand in legal fees
what is that about does it have anything
to do with the arrest from this week no
it doesn't but we will talk about it on
the bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com
to get instant access